vous voulez acheter un iphone fin 2022
début 2023 alors je vais vous aider
parce que je vous ai déjà fait une vidéo
en début d'année pour vous montrer pour
vous guider pour vous aider en tout cas
essayer de trouver quel iPhone acheter
début 2022 il s'est passé des choses
entre-temps bah ouais il y a un iPhone
se qui est sorti et puis surtout les
iPhone 14 14 + qui est arrivé nouveau
format 14 pro 14 pro max les autres
iPhone ont un petit peu bougé au niveau
du prix donc les choses se décale
légèrement on va donc essayer
aujourd'hui de faire le tour pour voir
quel iPhone acheter fin 2022 début 2023
même beaucoup début 2023 vous êtes prêts
allez on y va
alors il y a plein de choses à venir
raconter pour parler justement les
iPhone la première chose ça va être de
quelle manière on va venir l'acheter
est-ce qu'on veut un smartphone neuf
est-ce qu'on va smartphone en
reconditionné à ce qu'on va smartphone
en occasion alors le 9 c'est sera mieux
parce qu'il est neuf il a pas vécu payer
une garantie de deux ans vous êtes
tranquille le reconditionné c'est la
meilleure option après si vous voulez un
smartphone un peu moins cher par rapport
au prix du neuf il faut savoir un truc
qui est très important c'est que les
iPhone il conservent un truc qui est
très élevé c'est la valeur réside du L
ça veut dire c'est ce qui reste du prix
de votre iPhone une fois qu'il est sorti
du magasin et une fois qu'il a été usé
ça c'est un truc qui est assez atypique
qu'on retrouve quasiment que sur les
iPhone même que sur les iPhone et bien
c'est que elle reste très élevée c'est à
dire un iPhone qui a été acheté en
magasin un an deux ans après sur vendra
quand même assez haut par rapport à un
Android par rapport à un Samsung où les
prix vont tout de suite baisser beaucoup
plus fortement trois à six mois après là
par contre votre iPhone vous allez en
tirer de l'argent et ce qui fait aussi
qu'un iPhone ça coûte de l'argent ça
coûte un peu d'argent quand même même si
vous allez l'acheter en reconditionné
alors attention je parle bien de
reconditionner je vous conseille pas
nécessairement l'occasion parce que
l'occasion vous n'avez aucune garantie
derrière la différence c'est que le
reconditionné c'est un reconditionneur
professionnel dès lors que vous allez
voir reconditionneur de bonne qualité
allez le faire en France je vous le
conseille réellement versus de
l'occasion c'est un particulier un
particulier il y a pas de garantie sauf
s'il l'achetait il y a moins de deux ans
qui est encore la garantie que la
facture vous avez auquel cas vous pouvez
y aller sinon s'il y a moins de
problèmes et bien vous en êtes pour
votre poche ça il faut le savoir alors
maintenant différentes choses qu'on va
venir regarder pour savoir quel iPhone
venir acheter la première chose et bien
ça va être le format comment vous voulez
votre iPhone soit il y a plein de
formats différents au niveau des iPhone
des petits des grands des moyens bref le
format c'est important au-delà du format
il y a un autre truc ça va être la
puissance la puissance la performance ça
dépend des usages que de toute façon les
plus Apple reste des puces performantes
sauf si vous commencez en plus qui
vieillissent un petit peu bon je vais
vous montrer ça autre qui nous intéresse
gros c'est forcément c'est le prix hein
mais ça le prix vous savez mieux que moi
quel budget vous pouvez mettre là-dedans
je vous dis une fois de plus il y a 9 il
y a une reconditionné à venir regarder
ensuite il y a la partie photo qui est
aussi un élément très important et
aujourd'hui un des éléments les plus
importants il y a notre truc auquel on
pense pas nécessairement qui est très
important c'est la notion de la 5G tous
les iPhone ne sont pas 5G donc on va
venir regarder les caisses on 5G
lesquels ne sont pas une autre question
qui est aussi importante c'est la
question du stockage alors ça on va en
parler rapidement vous allez voir c'est
pas très compliqué voilà ça nous fait
déjà pas mal de petits éléments à venir
voir et puis surtout surtout je pense
que vous le savez un iPhone ça coûte de
l'argent puisque on en parle ici donc si
vous arrive le moins de problèmes vous
risquez de râler pensez donc à venir
protéger votre smartphone parce que si
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est réalisée
avec mon partenaire rhinoshield qui vous
propose de venir protéger vos iPhone
très facilement et avec plein de
produits hyper canon alors vous en avez
dans tous les univers chérie vous allez
notamment avoir regardé les clear case
alors les clear Kayes sont quoi ce sont
des coques transparentes qui vont venir
protéger vos iPhone vous le mettez sur
votre iPhone très facilement comme ça
vous voyez le dos vous profitez d'un
très jolie design de l'iPhone mais pour
autant vous venez réellement le protéger
ça c'est hyper canon on va également
venir retrouver les modenix le mode
énigme c'est aussi hyper canon vous avez
le Verseau qui interchangeable comme ça
vous venez customiser votre iPhone très
facilement on va ensuite avoir à la
solitude alors la solitude on la connaît
c'est la coque un petit peu plus
standard avec des designs qui sont super
canon ici on est dans l'univers Star
Wars on va être sur Rick et Morty on va
être sur Marvel Spider-Man j'en passe
des meilleurs on va également l'avoir
sur un design transparent et bien Doctor
Strange One Piece qui aussi juste
piscine et puis voyez la coque
totalement transparente qui vous permet
d'avoir de la recharge sans fil max safe
disponible à partir des iPhone 12 12 13
14 sauf les modèles MINI et vous avez
également le grip max il vient se
positionner derrière votre iPhone comme
ça ça fait off deux poignets comme ça
vous tenez votre iPhone très facilement
comme ça j'ai mon iPhone à la main et ça
c'est très cool alors on a également sur
le modèle Max comme ça mais on l'a
également en mini mes chéris aussi vous
pouvez venir également personnaliser
totalement notamment vos solides suite
on y mettant une photo on y mettant un
texte on y gravant vos initiales ou
pourquoi pas venir dans une décolab qui
sont super canon il y en a énormément le
Seigneur des Anneaux League of Legends
Marvel Disney Star Wars Game of Thrones
Dragon Ball Z la NBA le PSG One Piece my
hero academia bref il y en a énormément
je vous laisse regarder je vous mets le
lien dans la description pour aller
découvrir tous les produits de
rhinoshield et en plus de ça bonne
nouvelle profitez de moins 5% de remise
avec le code gros 23 GRR 23 ça c'est une
très bonne nouvelle donc pensez
réellement à venir protéger votre iPhone
vous n'avez que l'embarras du choix
alors là je vous parle bien évidemment
des iPhone mais ils sont également
disponibles pour des airpods et pour
énormément de produits ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle et merci à rhinoshield d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo ok alors le
format c'est un truc très important
pourquoi parce que il y a cinq formats
différents au niveau des iPhone le plus
petit plus petit taille de l'écran plus
petit dans la poche qui aura pourtant un
écran pas trop mal je montre c'est le
mini alors le mini c'est l'iPhone que
Apple a arrêté de produire bon on va
revenir là-dessus ensuite vous avez le
see alors le mini il faut savoir que
vous avez un écran de 5,4 pouces avec
une encoche c'est différent différentes
laisse ceux qui gardent le design un peu
classique des iPhone tel qu'on l'avait
il y a longtemps vous savez où les
iPhone 7 des iPhone 8 des iPhone 6 et
l'iPhone se il est sympa mais vous avez
ici un écran qui est un peu plus petit
c'est du 4,7 pouces il est plus gros
avec un écran plus petit que le mini qui
est plus petit avec un écran plus grand
vous avez suivi l'histoire ensuite voir
arriver les iPhone un petit peu plus
classique c'est-à-dire l'iPhone 12
l'iPhone 13 l'iPhone 14 c'est un format
standard ensuite on va retrouver pour la
première fois cette année le 14 plus
jusqu'à avoir ce format n'existait pas
on avait le modèle plus existé jusqu'au
8 8 plus 7 plus etc on va ensuite
arriver sur les 14 pro alors les 14 pro
c'est exactement enfin 14 je vous mets
14 mais ça va être le 13 ça peut être le
12 et si ça c'est exactement le même
format que vous avez ici au niveau du
modèle un peu plus standard et puis
ensuite vous avez de très grand format
c'est le format qui s'appelle le pro Max
qui lui est juste monstrueux c'est ce
que j'utilise moi un pro max c'est très
grand ça dépasse des poches ça dépasse
des sacs mais on a un grand écran on a
une belle qualité et c'est ce qu'Apple
fait le mieux en tout cas du plus grand
aujourd'hui donc voilà un peu au niveau
des formats petit aparté au niveau du se
le se vous en avez deux qui restent
aujourd'hui actuel vous avez le modèle
de 2020 et vous avez le modèle qui est
sorti cette année vous en douterez 2022
si vous regardez cette vidéo en 2022
sinon c'était le modèle de l'année
d'avant si vous êtes en 2023 voilà
bienvenue aujourd'hui du futur la
question à se poser c'est est-ce que
vous voulez un tout petit iPhone petit
discret on va aller sur le mini ou le se
alors il faut savoir que Apple a arrêté
les formats mini on peut toujours venir
en acheter regardez par exemple si vous
allez sur le site d'Apple vous allez au
niveau des iPhone 13 là vous trouverez
toujours un iPhone 13 mini vous voyez
c'est le seul 13 mini le 13 le 13 mini
disponible au tarif de 809 € qui quand
même assez cher je vous conseille de
venir regarder en reconditionné parce
que si vous venez fouiller aux
reconditionné j'avais vu un iPhone 12
mini reconditionné vous voyez vous
pouvez le trouver à 479 euros dans un
état qui est pas mal alors après ça
dépend une fois de plus de l'État 639
euros 499 479 voyez c'est un peu ici que
ça vient aussi donc ça il faut le savoir
donc le mini moi je préférerais osse
pourquoi parce que vous avez
effectivement cet encoche qui est
aujourd'hui classique sur tous ces
iPhones parce que le se garde un design
d'un petit peu plus ancien et puis sera
un peu plus grand en taille en format
réel que le mini mais avec un écran plus
petit 4,7 pouces voilà donc ça une fois
de plus c'est un vrai parti pris je
pense pas que ce soit les iPhone qui se
vendent le plus mais si vous voulez un
tout petit format ça peut être
intéressant après il y a un truc qui est
intéressant c'est que je vous le disais
au niveau des formats cette ligne là et
cette ligne là au niveau de la truc un
peu standard et du pro c'est exactement
la même chose en terme de format donc ça
ça va bien si après on va aller un peu
plus grand mais qu'on veut pas avoir
trois optiques on veut venir économiser
un peu maîtriser plus son budget mais
c'est la première fois qu'Apple nous
ressort le format plus avec le 14 + qui
est intéressant mais qui reste quand
même aussi lui relativement onéreux de
toute façon c'est une évidence que si on
veut venir sur un iPhone on sait que ça
va être un peu cher bien évidemment
d'autant plus que en période d'inflation
tout augmente et ça pique un petit peu
vous voyez le 14 plus on est à partir de
1169 euros c'est quand même un budget
qui est quand même relativement et après
ils sont venus une fois de plus le plus
grand et bien c'est le pro max c'est
énorme donc voilà posez-vous vraiment la
question du format vers lequel vous
souhaiteriez aller lequel vous
conviendrait le mieux parce que c'est un
truc très très important autre élément
et je vous en parle tout de suite tant
que je vous tiens hein partez pas
regardez hop là c'est la question de la
5G alors parce que c'est un truc très
très important aujourd'hui la plupart
des opérateurs vont vous proposer des
abonnements 5G donc si vous avez pris un
abonnement 5G mais que votre smartphone
ne permet pas de recevoir la 5G et bien
vous n'aurez pas la 5G même si vous avez
l'abonnement 5G je pense que c'est clair
à savoir et je vous le disais justement
tout à l'heure le see de 2020 lui par
exemple il est 4G donc ici vous n'aurez
pas la 5G si vous voulez un iPhone avec
de la 5G il faut commencer à arriver à
partir des iPhone 12 là vous allez avoir
de la 5G tout ce qui va être iPhone
antérieur iPhone 11 sont des iPhone 4G
dans l'iPhone 11 je vous dis on inclut
aussi le se de 2020 et si vous voulez un
format se vous allez sur le se de 2022
qui lui est 5G vous voyez donc il y a
vraiment ça à venir se dire donc on peut
trouver des fois des iPhone 11 qui sont
super canon et à des tarifs très très
maîtrisés je reviens ici par exemple
vous voyez iPhone 11 alors on va sur le
11 pro je vous explique pourquoi est-ce
que le 11 il faut pas aller dessus dans
quelques instants vous trouverez un
petit peu moins de 500 balles mais c'est
un iPhone 4G il faut le savoir donc si
vous voulez un iPhone 5G en
reconditionné on va aller sur un 12 par
exemple ici et un 12 qu'on va trouver à
presque 600 balles vous voyez 579 et
plus si affinités et alors l'autre truc
dont je voulais vous parler qui est
aussi super important on va essayer
d'économiser un peu de papier c'est au
niveau des iPhone 11 si vous vous en
fichez d'avoir de la 5G et que l'iPhone
11 vous va très bien l'iPhone 11 était
très déjà très très bon en photo en
vidéo super stabilisation très très bon
résultat il y avait une vraie différence
au niveau des écrans ce qui fait que
l'iPhone 11 aujourd'hui j'ai pas trop
venir le recommander je suis plutôt vous
recommander de venir vers l'iPhone 11
pro et vers l'iPhone 11 pro max pourquoi
parce que une différence le 11 c'est une
dalle LCD qui marche bien Apple maîtrise
très bien c'est dalle les calibres très
bien mais à partir du 11 pro et du 11
max là on est arrivé sur de l'eau LED et
l'olyte c'est quand même autre chose des
noirs plus profonds plus belle qui a été
d'image bref ce qui fait que aujourd'hui
si on veut acheter un iPhone qui est un
peu plus ancien et qu'on s'en fout de la
5G je pense quand même que le 11 il faut
venir l'oublier et si je viens regarder
une fois de plus sur reconditionné on
était sur du 12 là si je retourne sur le
11 pro je vous dis on est quasiment à
500 balles et si vous allez sur le 11
vous le trouvez ouais 100 balles de
moins mais sans mal de moins parce qu'on
a une dalle qui est aussi pas
complètement folle donc voilà il y a ça
alors puisque je vous tiens une fois de
plus on va regarder un autre point qui
est important on va se mettre juste ici
si vous regardez les tarifs ils vont
aussi changer en fonction du stockage et
alors le stockage ne descendez jamais en
dessous de 64 Go aujourd'hui 64 Go ça
reste quand même petit parce qu'on
stocke beaucoup de photos dans le
téléphone beaucoup d'applications
beaucoup de vidéos enfin bref beaucoup
de choses ça reste quand même limite
limite je vous conseille quand même de
partir au minimum sur 128 Go de stockage
64 bon si il y a que ça que ça passe
dans le budget allez-y mais dites vous
bien qui arrive un moment il va falloir
effacer des choses il va falloir faire
des choix si vous pouvez monter
davantage en stockage faites-le mais
après ça reste toujours une question de
budget de façon c'est toujours la base
parce que si vous pouviez si vous
n'aviez pas la question de budget je
suppose que vous prendriez un iPhone 14
pro probablement probablement d'ailleurs
dites-le-moi dans les commentaires au
sujet qui est super important c'est la
partie photo la partie photo vidéo
aujourd'hui c'est l'élément je veux dire
presque central on veut tous de bonnes
photos on veut faire belles photos on
veut garder des souvenirs alors il y a
une différence à connaître au niveau des
gammes je sais pas si vous la connaissez
on va dire sur la gamme normale on va
l'appeler la gamme normale on va la
différencier de la gamme pro et bien
vous avez pas exactement la même chose
en photo sur la gamme normale vous avez
deux capteurs vous allez avoir ce qu'on
appelle le grand-angle c'est le capteur
principal et vous avez également un
ultra grand-angle vous savez qui permet
de prendre en photo des bâtiments avec
un plus grand angle sans forcément venir
se reculer tandis que sur le Pro vous
avez effectivement le grand angle vous
avez effectivement l'ultra grand-angle
mais vous avez en plus un téléobjectif
qui lui va vous permettre de venir
zoomer dans l'image là vous allez
pouvoir venir zoomer mais c'est un zoom
numérique donc on va venir dégrader la
qualité le truc qui va être intéressant
si vous avez les pépettes et ça on le
sait je sais pas si vous le savez
d'ailleurs dites-le-moi et bien sûr
l'iPhone 14 pro 14 pro max cette année
on a des capteurs de 48 mégapixels ça
permet d'avoir un zoom numérique en plus
du zoom analogique ce qui fait que
lorsque vous allez venir zoomer ici vous
allez avoir un X 2 numérique on vient
zoomer dans 48 mégapixels on sort une
photo 24 mégapixels et après vous
arrivez sur un X 3 optique là sur le X 2
c'est le grand angle qui fait la photo
et le X 3 on commence sur le
téléobjectif comme ça ça offre pas mal
de possibilités mais si vous venez ici
là et vous voulez faire un X3 sur votre
smartphone classique et bien vous êtes
directement en numérique donc plus vous
allez zoomer et plus vous allez bien
dégrader la qualité donc est-ce que le
téléobjectif c'est vraiment important
pour vous oui non si c'est vraiment
important allez sur un modèle Pro les
modèles pro existent à partir de
l'iPhone 11 pro avant ça n'existait pas
donc voilà après il faut savoir que les
iPhone et je vous le dis moi depuis
l'iPhone 11 je trouve que ça c'était
vraiment amélioré que la photo elle est
plus loin photo et vidéo donc bon vous
trouverez toujours de très bon
smartphone dans cette gamme là le truc
qui est intéressant c'est de venir faire
un comparatif pour regarder le on va
regarder les derniers iPhone on va se
regarder l'iPhone 13 l'iPhone 14 et on
va se mettre l'iPhone 12 vous allez voir
c'est intéressant de venir regarder un
peu ce qui se passe parce que il vous
met 100 balles d'éclairage à chaque fois
ça honnêtement pour l'iPhone 12 vous
pouvez le trouver en reconditionné
l'iPhone 13 ouais mais faites attention
et vraiment chez des reconditionneurs
Français pour pas avoir de blague là il
y a un truc qui est très très cool c'est
que vous êtes toutes ces dalles là vous
allez le voir un peu plus bas vous êtes
sur un écran OLED donc ça c'est vraiment
important les résolutions seront
sensiblement les mêmes ce qui va
vraiment apporter une différence ici
vous allez le voir c'est au niveau du
design à partir de l'iPhone 13 on a une
encoche qui a été plus petite qui a été
réduite sur ses iPhone là et à partir de
l'iPhone très bonne 14 pro est arrivé
dynamic Island vous savez cette petite
île dynamique que Apple vient utiliser
pour mettre des animations pour vous
montrer différentes choses et faire
comme si cette espèce de protubérance au
milieu est en fait un truc super bon ça
en service c'est pas mal on s'y habitue
j'ai pas craché dessus mais ça reste
quand même une partie de l'écran qui
n'est pas là parce qu'il faut mettre
faceidy la caméra true Dave bref c'est
comme ça encore aujourd'hui vous voyez
qu'avant sur l'iPhone 12 bien vous aviez
de l'encoche n'était pas tout à fait la
même donc il y a trois types de design
aujourd'hui au niveau des iPhone on va
voir c'est encoche qui est un peu plus
grosse elle est un peu plus petite et
puis là dynamique Island sur le modèle
Pro sinon vous êtes quand même sur la
même encoche ici mais dans tous les cas
vous êtes sur une très belle dalle OLED
il y a absolument aucun problème ici les
tailles d'écran seront les mêmes si vous
êtes sur le modèle un peu standard bon
après ça va dépendre une fois de plus et
je vous parle tout à l'heure du format
l'idée de la photo est sensiblement la
même vous avez juste une différence au
niveau de la photo attention ça il faut
vraiment le savoir sur l'iPhone 12 Pro
parce que il y a une différence entre
l'iPhone 12 Pro et l'iPhone 12 Pro max
l'iPhone 12 Pro max aura une ouverture
qui sera un peu plus basse on ira un peu
plus loin qu'on lui sont de faible
luminosité mais tout ça ça se tient dans
un mouchoir de poche et une différence
également au niveau du télé objectifs à
pas grand chose mais il y a une petite
différence qui existe et il fallait
souligner alors après le truc vraiment
sur quel j'attire vraiment attention je
sais pas si vous l'avez vu je vous ai
fait une vidéo pour vous en parler de
l'iPhone 14 l'iPhone 14 c'est un iPhone
13 ni plus ni moins c'est exactement la
même chose c'est le même design vous
allez avoir exactement la même puce et
c'est la première fois qu'Apple sur une
génération d'après nommé exactement la
même puce la seule différence c'est que
vous avez un cœur de GPU en plus le GPU
ça gère toute la partie graphique sinon
tout ce qui va être performance
puissance lcpu et c'est la même chose
donc vous voyez franchement ici vous
avez exactement la même chose donc
iPhone 13 iPhone 14 et vous trouvez un
iPhone 13 reconditionné en France
allez-y sinon l'iPhone 14 globalement il
servira pas vraiment à grand chose donc
on va on va venir un peu passer notre
tour ici donc on va regarder en réalité
aller l'iPhone 13 ou l'iPhone 14 c'est
la même chose on va regarder l'iPhone 12
et on va regarder l'iPhone 11 pro
puisque l'iPhone 11 on a dit qu'au
niveau de l'écran ça nous intéressait
pas réellement alors il y a une
différence un peu au niveau de la dalle
ici on les avait fait des changements
ici déjà au niveau des tailles des
dalles voyez parce que sur le modèle
iPhone 11 pro on était à 5,8 parce que
sur le 12 Pro l'été à 6,1 donc bon il y
a eu des petites évolutions des fois
c'est des constructions de gamme qui
sont comme ça mais on va se dire que
c'est sensiblement la même chose ça il
faut aussi venir le savoir même dalle
taille d'écran un peu différente des
petites variantes au niveau des zoom
optiques il y a vraiment un truc qui est
important c'est la question de la puce
parce que même s'il y a Apple a toujours
des puces qui sont performantes plus tu
t'en passe et plus c'est plus deviennent
entre guillemets un peu plus obsolètes
alors aujourd'hui on vous met sur
l'iPhone 14 la puce A15 mais en réalité
la plus de cette année c'est la puce à
16 ce qui fait que lorsque vous remontez
jusqu'à un iPhone 11 Pro vous êtes sur
la puce à 13 fatalement alors elle reste
toujours actuelle mais elle sera quand
même moins actuelle que celle de
l'iPhone 12 et celle de l'iPhone 13 donc
l'iPhone on se prend pour faire tourner
beaucoup de jeux dessus il y aura aucun
problème et si vous voulez des trucs
extrêmement gourmands vous risquez un
moment de se dire bon c'est sympa mais
on voudrait un peu plus et je vous le
disais tout à l'heure une fois de plus
la question de la 4G versus la 5G alors
après il y a eu plein de petites
évolutions qui sont arrivées le
céramique chill qu'on a eu à partir de
l'iPhone 12 et qu'on n'avait pas sur
l'iPhone 11 il a fait d'avoir la
recharge sans fil le max save qu'on
adapté à partir de l'iPhone 12 et pas de
l'iPhone 11 on a le mode cinématique on
a partir de l'iPhone 13 et l'iPhone 14
je dirais que même aujourd'hui si vous
voulez aller sur des iPhones on va
commencer à aller à partir de l'iPhone
11 c'est l'iPhone à partir duquel je
peux commencer à aller mais ceux d'avant
on va vraiment pas y aller le 17 10 16
max le 17 le 10 le 8 et compagnie tout
ça on n'en veut pas c'est vraiment passé
le 11 on peut commencer à y aller
attention une fois de plus vous dis 11
c'est LCD faut aller sur les pros pour
avoir de l'eau LED ici on a de la 4G il
y a des choses qu'on a pas il y a pas de
recherche sans fil mais bon ça reste un
iPhone qui est quand même intéressant à
partir de l'iPhone 12 c'est une autre
histoire le phone 12 il est hyper canon
12 12 Pro 12 mini 12 Pro Max qui sont
canons ensuite le 13 on peut y aller
aussi les 13 pro pro max 13000 oui le 13
bien par contre le 14 on y va pas parce
que le 14 est un iPhone 13 on l'a déjà
vu la seule chose qui est intéressante
ici sont les modèles pro les modèles pro
max et surtout le truc qui est vraiment
vraiment intéressant cette année qui est
hyper canon c'est l'iPhone plus qui lui
a un plus grand écran tout en gardant
l'ADN d'un iPhone 13 d'un iPhone 14
alors voilà un peu pour cette idée je
sais pas si ça vous aura aidé mais
l'idée vraiment c'est de se dire OK si
vous voulez un iPhone et que vous avez
un budget qui est un petit peu resserré
tout ce qui est en bas on y va pas je
vous recommanderai à ce moment-là de
vous trouverez un bon Android alors
effectivement Android c'est pas iOS on
est d'accord là-dessus au niveau de
l'expérience mais pour autant Android ça
marche super bien il y a une super belle
expérience toujours une question
d'habitude donc des fois on a du mal à
switcher mais mieux vaut des fois venir
changer ses habitudes pour avoir un
smartphone performant qui fait de bonnes
photos qui sera extrêmement polyvalent
et qui ira bien plutôt que se taper une
vieille grave sur iOS qui qui ne marche
pas donc n'allez pas sur des trop vieux
iPhone ma vraie recommandation le vrai
bon plan truc qui peut être intéressant
c'est aujourd'hui de trouver un iPhone
13 ou un iPhone 12 avoir le format à
voir si vous voulez le pro ou pas le pro
c'est vraiment les super bons plans je
vous le dis une fois de plus venez
regarder en reconditionné parce que vous
arrivez qu'à votre première chose
intéressante si je vais sur un iPhone 12
en reconditionné vous voyez je suis à
presque 600 euros et je trouve un truc
qui est très cool alors après ça dépend
des fois plus du stockage elle a 128 il
est quand même plus élevé mais bon 64 on
peut commencer à faire des choses donc
voilà ma recommandation iPhone 12 iPhone
13 et une fois de plus ça va dépendre
vous de votre argent alors j'espère que
ces quelques éléments de compréhension
vous auront aidé vous permettront de
venir choisir un iPhone et de trouver
l'iPhone vous correspond fin 2022 début
2023 d'ailleurs dites-le-moi en bas dans
les commentaires puis surtout dites-moi
quel iPhone est fait pour vous en cette
fin d'année début d'année prochaine
lequel vous avez envie d'acheter et une
fois que vous avez regardé cette vidéo
est-ce que ça vous ça a servi est-ce
qu'il y a des éléments qui vous ont aidé
est-ce que ça a été clair dites-le-moi
ça permettra de m'améliorer d'être
toujours plus loin pour la prochaine
vidéo que je ferai probablement 2023 il
y aura toujours des petites mises à jour
à faire voilà je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous et à très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]